continuing our coverage of the 2020
scouting combine in indianapolis our
next guest finished his second season as
head coach of the tennessee titans with
a birth in the afc championship he is
mike frable back on the program coach
congratulations i mean i know i know
you want to win it all but still you got
to be damn proud of what you've done in
two years to get the team as far as it's
come from two and four this year making
the switch to ryan tannehill and it was
fun to watch yeah what i'm proud of is
our players and their effort uh and
their finish and how they played and how
they responded to a little bit of
adversity the one thing i'll be most
proud of is this past season is that we
didn't have a whole lot of front runners
uh when you start two and four uh it's
real easy to
to start complaining and pointing
fingers and our guys didn't do that um
and and and nobody acted like a front
runner and and i'll be proud of that
well that that's a credit to you i mean
that's kind of the aura you give off so
i think you uh that's me trying to give
you a compliment i appreciate it yeah um
but also with your your quarterback just
explain to that like his attitude the
way he is what what made it work why did
he fit you know and and the things
you're talking about the thing i noticed
early on is when we signed ryan or and
we traded for him um is he came in and
you have to learn i mean you know you've
learned different systems and again the
plays
a lot of them are similar but they're
called something different and that is
very hard to be able to to master the
terminology the looks uh the reads the
progression the
you know
the run game you know how we want to
handle the run game the things that we
want to can to and how we want to
manipulate our run game right and he
learned all that and he supported marcus
and i think that will be the thing that
i'll look back and be thankful for ryan
as he supported he didn't agree with the
role who would who would ever say i want
to be a backup um but he supported uh
that decision and then when given the
opportunity um he excelled
his leadership uh blossomed right and
and that that was something that i'll
i'll look back and be thankful for when
did you first start deliberating whether
or not ryan should be the guy instead of
marcus the change was already made
during the sixth game sure when did you
first have that that that synapse fire
in your brain that maybe he should be
the guy um
[Music]
you know always evaluating the team i
mean you guys evaluate the show and what
you like about it and what you don't
like about no we don't no he's still
here we don't know you guys put a lot of
time in there you guys you guys have um
obviously improved um
in what you've done but that's that's my
job is to evaluate the things that we do
well and try to continue that and
enhance it and then fix the things that
we don't do well um
and we weren't doing a whole lot of
things well you know
offensively at that point in time and um
just felt like we needed a spark and we
needed all need to play better what what
is it about his physical attributes that
you really like i mean you know he's
great athlete he's got size his down the
field throwing was off the charts this
year um
you know he really grasped the concept
of how we wanted to play the football
game yeah and be able to run it uh play
pass take some shots
and then he helped us when protection
broke down or we asked him to run um you
know in the keeper game he was able to
get out on the edge and right um and
extend plays and do some things down
down the field
um
i i just i i would feel cheated if i
didn't ask you this but like you know
just your thoughts oh your boss would
get mad at you yeah he might you're
right so
you calling him my boss over there so he
gets it he knows he knows how it goes i
work life my boss everybody everybody's
got a boss everybody's got a boss um but
uh i do want to ask you just about the
afc championship game you guys see
patrick mahomes twice this year just you
know again he's the man of the moment
right now just what jumps out to you
evaluating him and then seeing him in
person on the field
uh you know just his his composure i
think um
under under duress you know there were
times that um in both games that that we
either pressured him or had a guy free
and he would drift and and be able to
throw to spots
uh down the field you know 15 or 20
yards in front of a receiver that he
knew would be there um
you know his ability to obviously extend
plays um cost us you know in the afc
championship game among other things but
um you know when you have a quarterback
that
can stand in the pocket can deliver to
football uh on time and then also extend
plays it makes it harder to defend
have you ever seen a quarterback who
like floats backwards like he does like
for you as a pass rusher outside
linebacker guy like
is that weird well it's just difficult
because you know you think you're
gaining on him and you're really not
he's just drifting he's bringing you one
arm straight yeah the arm strength
to be able to throw the football um
without setting his feet is something
that um you know is very impressive yeah
how do you strike the balance with your
defensive players about treating a
quarterback who chooses to run the ball
like a running back because you had to
be frustrated on that run to the end
zone now i know some of it is his
athleticism and elusiveness but i just
feel like when a quarterback strays
toward the sidelines sometimes defensive
players we like their coach to hit them
their their coach to hit them as hard as
they possibly can as legally as they
possibly can
um but do do you see what we see where
sometimes it's the quarterback stays
toward the sideline guys start to pull
up or or even a guy you know here's what
happens sometimes guys slide guys slide
guys slide and then all of a sudden on
the third or fourth one they don't slide
right and guys are pulling off because
you know we're coach is a very fine line
our guy is a coach to go full tilt to
the tackle and uh
there's an element of judgment and
composure
as that play is ending whether it's an
offensive lineman you know
finishing a guy over the pile or pushing
the pile
or a defensive player that's going after
the quarterback there's an element of of
a decision making and a composure that
they have to have when a mobile
quarterback scrambles and then chooses
to slide late like that it's on the
defender does it drive you crazy as the
next offender
it doesn't i mean that's the rules i
know that's what we have to try to coach
yeah as long as we can coach it as long
as we can do our best to coach the
player when they ask coach what am i
supposed to do if i don't have an answer
that's a that's a bad place to be in i
saw it happen this weekend in the xfl i
know you don't watch the xfl i do pj
walker yeah started to pull up at the
sideline slowed down and just shot back
into he's done some really good things
hasn't he i guess he has he's able to
extend plays cardel jones i watched him
play the other day obviously wanted to
follow and see what cardel did um from
from ohio state in the time that we
spent there together but uh certainly
looked like pj
was exciting the other day are you
watching that league with like keeping
notes telling guys uh john robinson hey
here's a guy maybe we want to take a
look at we'll evaluate it and our guys
our scouts are are watching those games
um you know i was curious about the
kickoff and and what that may look like
and if that's something that that we
would entertain as
as our league is something that you know
could help the game and make it better
and obviously make it safer trust me
jrobs in charge they're going to
evaluate the xfl guys i could tell you
that for sure what's the first
conversation with belichick like after
you beat him in the playoffs
um it's a quick one
just said thanks coach the same thing i
say i say good game
i appreciate uh appreciate you and then
uh
and then when you know
found carter
did you know about the loophole before
he used it and told the world about it
did you know about that for loophole
with delay game and all that you know
yeah we're very aware of what the rules
are um again we're just going to play by
the rules and um try to win when we can
uh you know use them to our advantage i
just thought it was so odd that he told
the world he used it in that i think it
was a monday night game yeah and cause
it's like hey maybe some guys that don't
know about this and uh you're flagging
it and it ended up getting used against
him but you already knew about it anyway
so it wouldn't have mattered yeah you
just we were never up big enough in the
fourth quarter to be able to use it
before in games we're usually the ones
that are in a one-score game so when are
you going to sign ryan tannehill
you know with free agency it's uh
it's a two-way street players have to
want to be back um and then teams have
to make decisions and there's a lot of
tough decisions that we have to make and
again appreciative of ryan and what he
did and i know that john and his staff
is you know they're working hard to try
to resign all our players that we went
back what about the other beast 22 derek
henry what's the thought there i mean
for just well the thought is he's just
you know
i felt like the thing that he improved
on the most was his leadership yeah and
that's unique from a running back i
don't think you know guys like eddie
george are great leaders i played with
eddie and i can comment on that but
sometimes you know runners you just kind
of hand them the ball and they kind of
do their thing right um
but i felt like his leadership skills
um
really
really grew throughout the season you
know when a play that we were putting in
for a game maybe didn't look great or we
hadn't run it as many times and it
didn't look great in practice and derek
would be the one that said hey run it
again
i didn't have to say anything guys got
lined up and they ran the play again and
so um i told him that after the season i
said you had a phenomenal year you led
the league in rushing you carried this
football team but you improved as a
leader right and and i don't want to
you know neglect that you're one of the
few teams that this question of whether
or not there's going to be new labor
deal affects the most because if there
isn't you get a franchise tag and a
transition tag could be used for
tannehill and for henry cowboys are in
that same boat maybe the buccaneers
depending upon what they do with jameis
winston
are you kind of hoping there isn't a new
cba so it's it creates some flexibility
you know all i want is for the league
and and for the players and having been
you know on both sides i know that when
you do a deal uh it's got to be good you
know for both people both people got to
leave a deal
feeling like they got something out of
it and uh you know i'm hoping as always
what's best for the league and what's
best for the players so i love coaching
i love coaching players and i i want to
be around players as much as i can is
there anything glaring that you could
share with us or you just look at it and
go i i this has to improve on our team
next year i mean maybe you don't want to
share it with us but no we had 31
pre-snap penalties okay so we complain
about you know being poor on third down
or needing to improve on third down uh
let's start there let's not let's start
there where instead of being in the
third and seven it's third and two right
or you know being able to convert and
not be in long-yardage situations so
let's see if we can stay on sides and
not move uh until the ball moves
defensively we got to get better in the
red zone we went from number one in the
league to 31st so
i don't know why we have to figure that
out we have to coach better let's play
better well it's been a great run so far
for you in tennessee we enjoy watching
it and we wish you all the best
appreciate it mike grebel titan's head
coach you're the master thanks guys good
luck thanks thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports